what up this is black and this is my
tattoo tour
[Music]
the craziest thing is that my first
tattoo was absolutely during spring
break
it wasn't a crazy tattoo but it was
definitely my first one this was College
spring break I was at Valdosta State
stopped by a random tattoo shop and I
didn't know what to get and the word
self-made just popped up in my head and
that was it just some little cursive
just self-made keep it simple nothing I
regret later I always knew that I had a
high interest in tattoos but I didn't
get one when I was growing up because I
lived with my mom and she was basically
just like if you live here these are my
rules and when you go out there you can
do whatever you want to do when I saw
Wiz is like full Montage coming up
during like the flight school cushion
orange juice how fly era I was like oh
those are crazy tattoos and then Wayne I
think Wayne is like an obvious from the
beginning of the time he had some very
pivotal tattoos and tattoos that people
can remember by photo shoot and remember
by music video so then besides that I
was always drawing and sketches I like
to jot things down and eventually use
them later on in life a good portion of
my tattoos are either drawn by me or
edited by me I'm not married married to
like any one Artist as far as doing my
tattoos there's a guy who goes by ink by
Cali and from Atlanta who I work with a
lot shout out to him he did this sound
wave of the lead single from the last
album since I have a lover he did the
lover chat right there as well and then
I have a Mamba tattoo like right on the
back of my neck homage to Kobe my
favorite athlete of all time my favorite
basketball player my favorite mindset
when it came to Sports in general Mamba
mentality was how I looked at my music
when he passed that was one of the first
tattoos that I got a little Mamba
reference
this is one of my most recent ones I got
a Lotus Flower and I got Totoro uh
Studio Ghibli movies are some of my
favorite movies I got Gigi from Kiki's
Delivery Service those I believe are my
most recent ones it'll always be my most
favorite tattoo the bear claw because it
is symbolic of the moment when I knew I
would dedicate the rest of my life to
what I love which was my music it was
saying you might not be able to get a
real job with this and this was like
back during the times where tattoos were
still very frowned upon and just like oh
you can't be visible and got to be
presentable and you'll never get hired
like that so this was my moment of
saying I don't really want to be hired I
just want to do what I like I'm trying
to think of like most painful it's not
necessarily like the tattoos that are
the most painful it'll just be an area
so like anywhere near my wrist like I
have a Enzo Circle over here on the
right side it's in circles and this part
of the bear claw like when it gets near
that little bone in Mars it starts to
Rattle and that's definitely painful
every other part of it I try and like
feel it as therapeutic and I close my
eyes and listen to some music but when
it gets right there that's when like a
single tier might fall out of my eye
most of these on this arm have something
to do with interconnection or just like
my mind state so Enzo just kind of being
Mohammed to imperfection and finding the
beauty and things that aren't complete
and then that kind of connects right
into all these water symbols that just
recognize my birth chart and who I am a
Cancer you have a seed of life right
here which speaks to the Genesis pattern
and just how things are created and how
everything ends up being connected yeah
then a bunch of like neighboring things
like the cancer constellation more water
symbols a little crab right there yeah
this is my uh this is my woke arm I
guess then I got some dragons on this
side and I just got that after I binged
Game of Thrones and I was just like oh
yeah this is one of my shows and gotta
pay homage I love anything medieval
dragons magic kings queens longest to
him might have been this faded black
panther that needs to be touched up this
is also another one of my earliest ones
took the longest to heal because just of
all the shading and there was a moment
where I thought and like we have to be
almost done at this point and I looked
down and it was like this corner of it
shaded black and I was just like what I
just find animals that like I resonate
with the most so during that time Black
Panthers or Jaguars black bears those
were like my two animals that I pinged
off of the most I love their stealth I
love their strength I love their
Tranquility like when they're in their
own element and undisturbed the Panther
and the bear both were just like
monikers that I took to the most and
felt like I should uh pay homage to Bear
Claw back ahead trying to think if I
have any other like animals oh yeah I
got a little bear right there walking
that's just a geometric bear I feel like
if you've been on Pinterest you've seen
this one a bunch of times so Pinterest
is good for inspiration don't let
anybody tell you otherwise I have a few
tattoos that are dedicated to my
daughter and dedicated to my favorite
number I have six his name on my hand I
have a rose to represent her middle name
metatron's Cube which has six points in
it but also speaks to this arm and the
building blocks of everything that we
know and love physically and what it all
is made from yeah and then the number
six the digit I was just sketching on my
iPad it looks a lot uh more detailed
when you when you blow it up on the iPad
but for now it's cool I like it how it
is I think I might have told my girl
during the time but besides that it
wasn't like a premeditated I'm about to
eventually get my face tatted type of
thing my mom you know obviously was like
ah why you do that why you mark up your
face but it's tiny you know Barbara is
my grandmother this one of all the
grandparents that I have the one that I
was the most closest to I remember a
good portion of my childhood growing up
either around her or near her or you
know having visits back and forth from
Baltimore to Atlanta and spending time
with her after she passed this was my
tribute to her she was a very very sweet
lady Secrets not necessarily a secret I
have like a symbol just like that had no
defining meaning I was just kind of
making things again and I liked it and I
ended up getting a tattoo behind my ear
but I never really know what it looks
like and sometimes I could get like a
little bit of dry skin back there so it
just kind of stays tucked away and every
now and then somebody's like oh is that
a whatever then I'm like I honestly
don't know what it looks like back there
I have no idea if it's cool or not but
maybe one day I like put a mirror to it
and check it out I got one crescent moon
on my finger right here I got one
crescent moon right here along with all
the water symbols in my cancer sign if I
don't have any more I'm pretty sure I'll
end up with at least a couple more let
me see if I missed any that I want to
talk about oh yeah talk about it I have
talked about it right here on the
forearm I got this in the middle of tour
for me it was like during the time
period where I kept running into the
issue of having things that I was
thinking about or feeling and not
necessarily communicating it and then
later on it blows up in your face and
you're like all I had to do was say this
or do that and it would have completely
changed the course of my day sometimes I
just have to like glance down and give
myself a simple reminder if I'm feeling
it if I'm thinking it talk about it on
the backs of my like right above my he's
still in the Love Letter uh acronym that
was free on tour and the free album free
six album is right there too so those
are some of the cheapest ones most
expensive might have been the self-made
one of them which is crazy because it
was my first tattoo I went to a random
shop they told me some price and I was
just like cool sounds good to me and
when I say expensive too I feel like
something might have cost me a little
bit more but it's no reason why this
should have been like 350 during that
time yeah they got me it's all good
though spring breaker diamond in the
rough was it's kind of faded this is
another one I need to get like touched
up and sharpened but just a diamond
right here the words in the roof are
under it that to me just speaks to like
what I feel my process has been is my
life could have been a million different
things I've been in a million different
situations that have nothing to do with
like musicianship or stardom or like
having what you need to be in a place
where I have all the essentials and
things that I need and my people are
good diamond in the rough represents
that this is zone six this is like a rib
type that goes down the side zone six
pays homage to the neighborhood that I
grew up in it gave me a lot of
inspiration whether it was music related
whether it was just culture and how we
dressed whether it was dialect lingo
slang like that side of Atlanta was my
stomping ground for most if not all of
my life and even to this day I still
live on that side of town so zone six is
it's with me forever I got speed for my
cousin who passed away his nickname was
speed I got this one when Prince passed
away this was just my tattoo paint
homage to Prince there's a purple line
running through the bottom of it I got
this one in Atlanta yeah I guess I have
a good amount of like tattoos that pay
respects to people who are still here
with us but here in spirit I got a
compass because I'm weirdly obsessed
with knowing where I am at all times
directions and time and promptness and
like those are things that I just care
about
even though I was late today
foreign